what's up everyone welcome to
stimulation I'm your host Don sockin
pumped to be talking about the
computational Renaissance we have
Tristan Tyler Blake joining us on the
show hi Tristan it's a pleasure to see
you again brother it's you know it's
been a long time and we've spent so much
time together on the phone and just
discussing these incredible ideas so
really good time to be here and thank
you so much I look forward to this
discussion man I'm so pumped in yeah
your background is so epic for this
conversation we're about to have Tristan
Tyler Blake is the founder of machine
learning society and the co network
which are custom engineered social
networks for the acceleration of science
technology and culture you can find the
links in the bio below to the
computational Renaissance page as well
as innovation - labs CO and Tristan's
LinkedIn profile yeah we've been going
back and forth for quite some time now
on ideation around the future and what
the best social fabric is that's going
to be the most optimal design and
architecture of the protocols that
manifest the abundant prosperous future
that we're all seeking let's start with
a couple of our more spiritually
inclined questions sure are we really
all one you know as a person who loves
history and literature I believe we need
to rescue a lot of words from mediocrity
and I think in the spiritual realm you
know I often see that people use the
words like quantum and the words that
are dedicated to science and have a true
legitimate meaning and I feel like
they're competing with the scientific
one where actually they're just trying
to say the same thing from two or even
three different perspectives so are we
all one do we have a collective
consciousness I actually think we have
collective emotions a new class of
emotions that might be emerging could be
from social media could be from the
Internet but there are emotions that
come from within internally and then if
you have the type of radar that picks
that up an ecosystem
intelligence something that I believe
that our species is evolving then you
could pick up external emotions and
experiences that are collective to us
all and if the to misalign will you get
yourself a little bit of just friction
and so it's important to have your
external emotions or the collective ones
and the internal ones be compatible and
that's really I think the key to
happiness would you say that everything
is interconnected absolutely yes and you
know I often think in different Sciences
kind of so you're driving down this road
and you look down the mountain and you
see the sky and you see the trees and
that is all an ecosystem and it has its
own computational intelligence behind it
and there are sciences or fields of
exploration inquiry that we don't even
know how to ask about or how to question
or analyze but you know the trees are
related to the sky and related to the
mountains and the relationships are
difficult to identify because there's so
many of them yeah and it's about asking
the question in the right way and as as
we talked a little earlier every life
has 2.5 billion heartbeats not not 4
billions so all those thousands of
people that I told before it's 2.5
actually 25 billion if you live until
you're 82 yeah there you go
so if if so every life has two more five
billion heartbeats and I believe a
million questions and what I find as a
person that is passionate about data
science and algorithms is that it's
actually the order in which you ask
questions that really defines the
outcome that's right you know so if you
ask one question before the other you
get a non-answer you just you didn't ask
the question appropriately and I think
this moment in time this computational
Renaissance this period is epic period
actually it's about asking questions the
right questions in the right order yeah
that can yeah yeah and we'll dive into
that in a little bit more detail in a
little bit I want to ask you also what
do you think is the purpose of this
reality
you know I love the suggestion that
there is a purpose but when I look into
the Stars and into the sky I just feel
like the stars are really the purpose is
for stars to live and die and for the
universe to live and die everything
lives and dies so it's the purpose is to
understand what life is I think or just
to experience life as much as possible
every flavor every every type of
experience good and bad you know and and
I often have these experiences at home I
tell my friends about this but you know
I'll be reading history or writing
something and it's as if something takes
over and experience these I used to have
kidney stones a couple of years ago and
just terrible pain like eight out of ten
pain you know but these things you go
down just as hard on your knees except
these are eight of pleasure or of
clarity so I call them seizures of
clarity because you go down and you and
you see the world and you experience and
you just the types of things that truly
enable that kind of experience is to
think about numbers or sizes that are
overwhelming and that's when I'm
triggered so how many stars in the
galaxy are in the universe try to think
about that and that will simulate that
simulation attempt will literally blow
your mind you know and you can
experience what is a billion stars when
people think when I say the word billion
think of a billion stars you're actually
thinking about 20,000 50,000 probably
now multiply and multiply and multiply
that so when I look at a swimming pool I
see it trillion atoms of water and you
know water just just the molecules
interacting so there's there's kind of a
Big Data way of seeing the world a
perspective and then there's the actual
reality so I believe yeah the purpose is
to see the world from all of the
different angles and perspectives
yes very very eloquent I love the way of
of being able to see from these
different perspectives adding into a
more clear and true it's kind of like
the purpose of it is to see it from all
these different beautiful angles to have
these profound moments of awakening that
that feeling is exactly what this
beckons this reality beckons for you to
feel free to be dropped to your knees of
mind blowing this now over and over
again every day mind blowing this you
know love that I found that when you so
beauty is kind of like a bunny rabbit
it's so fast or was so fast and beauty
if you know sometimes you see a bunny
pop out and you try to get your phone to
capture capture a picture but the moment
you have it ready the bunny is gone long
gone and beauty is just like that when
you when something beautiful is in front
of you you almost don't have time to
appreciate it or even identify truly
examine it yeah right and and I think
some of the new technologies of
perception that we have and subconscious
kind of you know tweaking or
understanding your subconscious and
actually experiencing it
you can now capture reality in real time
and explore beauty and then effectively
understand the patterns of it so that
when you're walking around you could
actually see aspects of that beauty that
you captured maybe it could be culture
it could be a sound it could be a shape
it could be a geometry and then you
could apply that to this new beauty and
you see it all over again because you've
learned to recognize it in the past so
it's kind of funny the more beauty you
see the more you see it everywhere yeah
another one of the feelings for me
actually tying in all of the previous
questions that I've asked are these
feelings of the most deep profound
interconnectedness to all that is and
when I experience that feeling
it feels like the first of all that this
is my next question actually to you have
you experienced ego death before and yes
the experiences so I left my ego on an
airplane and one of the kind of
varmints and then I I forgot to pick it
up on the way out it was actually when I
came to San Diego I sort of I forgot I
left it on the flight you know I was
coming from New York like Wall Street
style you know kind of doing this thing
and and I just realized that that's
that's just not what makes me happy what
makes me happy is learning about the
nature of reality in the universe
investigating the conversations between
plants yes you know investigating the
the size of stars and their relative
sizes to each other these things are
just much more interesting to me than I
guess making money or kind of you know
those aspects you know so yeah that's I
experienced ego death a couple of times
and it's when I meet extraordinary
people that with profound intelligences
and and just just kind of humanity that
if you have ego you are missing the
opportunity to explore their geometry it
kind of it's a block or it's a filter
yeah on your reality your ego and
actually I've been telling my team my
amazing team that's sitting over there
love to talk a little bit about them
later but when you kind of just
experience reality as if it was a
touchscreen right here now imagine
there's a finger behind somewhere so
what if you were just to go back a
little bit now look at the screen and
you start to understand when you know my
work is in computer vision and
artificial intelligence the machine
learning society I try to look at the
world through the lens of a child's eyes
like a like a toddler what are the
learning patterns how is the interpret
information being interpreted and then
you go and you say we a robot needs to
understand what is a person what does a
microphone what is a computer what what
am i potentially later yes so you could
start to understand how a robot
interprets the world and that allows you
to go wait a minute
we are very neuromorphic
so if you just look at your own lens if
you zoom out you could see all the red
and blue circles and indicators and well
you could actually then decide this
indicator goes off and it's red negative
button you might enjoy that or you might
actually like it but your actual
character or your build your
architecture your scaffolding it doesn't
permit for you to experience that with
clarity without some noise being
introduced by your body so I listen to
my my mind rather than my body and my
and your body is the one that typically
adds layers of perception and goes I
like this or I don't like that whereas I
go no no what do I actually like and
it's like that touch screen that you
could modify your own weights so I have
up your your site so let's jump into
this there's a couple things that I want
to explore here you started us into this
computational Renaissance so we have we
have this is innovation - labs Co this
is magnetizing intelligence where we you
started giving us these ideas of
patterns pattern recognition from from
the perspective of a child when they're
born into the world how do they see the
world do the what inputs are they
starting to take in how are they
starting to understand the patterns same
thing with robots
same thing with perception found
curiosity profound curiosity and
starting to structure what is most
relevant for them like what are they
uniquely blueprinted for to do in this
world and then how do they then ask
questions about the reality to help them
bring what's blueprinted in them forth
into the world so a so let's have you
walk us through a couple of these things
there's there's some the ML Society CO
Network I want you to walk us through
there's there's one more thing that I
want to showcase as well which
is the computational Renaissance as well
so let's show this so this is on that
page when you click computational
Renaissance you dive here so teach us
about the difference between a mouse
society Co Network computational and
teachers walk us through all sure so you
know when I first came to San Diego I
didn't really know what my future would
be there I sort of came almost to get
warm so that I could head off to SF you
know over here with you guys but the
moment I touched down I just recognized
that there was this transformative
period this revolution going on and and
I was always very nostalgic about
missing the Einstein Neil Bora period
where they were kind of cutting the
nature of the atom they were splitting
it and understanding it and I felt like
I had lost an opportunity to be part of
an epic period but the moment I touched
down in San Diego I truly experienced
this like revival you know just this
awakening of curiosity and and an
opportunity so I started to explore and
I wanted to go to UCSD to to the data
science program because I just knew AI
was that I knew machine learning was a
answer to many questions that we didn't
even know how to ask yet and but my
grades were just horrendous you know
when I was younger I had to deal with
certain experiences that didn't allow me
to focus on my grades or you know a lot
of other things for that matter so in
San Diego I realized that I wouldn't be
able to join any program but no school
should take me really but I decide but I
still need to learn you know I still
need to be around this these people and
to absorb their and understand their
culture and their civilization that
they've engineered so I started hosting
these groups the machine learning
Society there's this moment where you
know I launched it in the third day
there was 60 people that were on the on
the group and I was like oh my god now I
have this responsibility to host to do
something to create value for them
otherwise I'm wasting their time
so I started hosting these events and
and it started with like these Kegel
competitions these data science
competitions you know for engineers to
kind of collaborate on on solving the
computer vision problems and natural
language processing problems and I was
just learning through that you know in
real time the the other thing is we
would host I just saw that the academic
world wasn't really providing a lot of
experiences for their sciences that
allowed them to actually connect so I
sort of hosting hikes with a data
scientist you know where people can walk
and talk about everything including
bioinformatics and physics and genomics
and all these incredible things and it
was very successful so I started to
scale my ambitions you know as you do as
you start to see cell immense of success
and I started hosting larger and larger
events until you know to our community
today we have about 30,000 impressions
you know social media with our email
campaigns and our actual physical
community in New York Boston San Diego
and one that's growing in the Bay Area
so it it's just about when you have all
these people in all of their attention
how do you actually concentrate it
towards outcomes that benefit them and
create ROI and that's I think that's
return on inspiration I love it so there
was this deep passion from you to get
involved in this computational
Renaissance you're coming to San Diego
this very silicon beach SoCal ask LA and
San Diego have so much of the cutting
edge that's happening this is very
important to keep in mind as a lot of
people are just looking at Silicon
Valley ok so then actually was
addressing those gravity gravity gravity
pulling you to and I really mean that
when I say gravity I've been exploring
this this external emotion as we were
mentioning earlier I've really been
feeling gravity and and something that I
kind of just saw was consciousness is
gravity consciousness is gravitational
it pull
and it can push to going towards solving
these big problems in NLP or computer
vision and trying to gather the
consciousness to focus on the big
problems and to advance the frontier of
AI I like this a lot so then let's let's
start wandering into you know you're
throwing you're throwing these events
you're throwing these competitions
you're seeing how you can focus
consciousness on tackling the big
challenges now you have communities that
have popped up around the world so let's
walk us through the then the differences
between ml society Co networks or
computational Renaissance and we'll
showcase them as as you go so from
today's lens you know it takes time to
truly understand context and to put
things into the proper boxes right to
contextualize them in the in the past
the machine learning society was just
this this instrument for attracting
intelligent people so that they can
collaborate it was very effective but
then I hit this scalability function
this this kind of I was looking at the
machine learner society as a community
and I really didn't know how I could
scale that until it was actually a dream
and it was a vision it was just this
moment and I remember when it happened
when I started thinking wait a minute
wait a minute this is not a community
anymore we've just transitioned we've
just moved into a network and the moment
I started seeing this from a network
perspective it fundamentally changed the
the transition towards a network allows
for scalability and that's borrowing
from data science and complexity theory
and all of these new Sciences that are
profoundly transforming the human
condition and our experience of it so
the moment I saw it was a network it
freed me to actually scale it pretty
much infinitely up using the
infrastructure of a network so the
machine learning society is a community
at the time and then I understood
meeting other groups that had
she learned society class problems so if
you think of a community as a egg right
with a with you know some sort of embryo
inside I started thinking what would an
egg carton look like or or something
that could incubate these communities
and turn them maybe into networks when
they hatch so the egg carton would be Co
Network which is essentially an
infrastructure for network design for
networks to operate and they if you
think of it almost any community or
network as a brain you start to see each
one of them requires communications
infrastructure event management jobs and
security like that storytelling right
just culture right culture is the
technology so all of these different
aspects are absolutely necessary for any
healthy community to to exist and to
continue to you know operate flourish
and and that's what cone Network was for
me it was this kind of how do I build a
templated infrastructure for any
community to expand and to operate on
this new paradigm of just connectivity
collaboration communication so yeah I
love that I love being able to like you
said focus in consciousness on tackling
the big challenges especially around the
future of artificial intelligences and
then you went and gave us this example
of how you need all of these different
pillars I like your brain more okay
I like your right now many is that I'm
gonna buy I love this a lot yeah because
there's all these different pillars of
the network design and the environment
for the community that can maximize the
flourishing of it I love that a lot
okay system think of things as systems
every system requires certain parts and
if you could systematize almost anything
and that's a technology that we're
developing now and we're gonna be you
know releasing shortly to the general
public but if you can create systems
that that that capture these patterns
and and replicate them pretty much
infinitely right AWS I mean that's what
it is it's
design a pattern and then scale it to
toe as much as your ambition allows so
yeah there's a certain I guess what
people need to appreciate is there's a
if you put enough energy and
infrastructure behind something there's
kind of a tipping point towards
inevitability and you need to know how
to understand and simulate that so I
think your simulation storytelling is
actually a lot in line with that theory
yeah yeah so a lot of it actually does
have to do with like you said this
building out this this this network
design to maximize the focus of
consciousness on tackling the problems
and then one of the big pillars is yeah
the story why are people doing it how
can we optimize the galvanizing process
of people's spirits in order to get them
going towards a given goal you sent me
over a computational Renaissance so
after you go to on the innovation - labs
Co once you get here you click
computational Renaissance on the left
and then it takes you over to the
computational Renaissance page so when
you were explaining this to me it was
really beautiful because I started
seeing things structured data basically
I was like structured data and let you
look at the column on the left and
there's hello world curiosity tracks
master takes cities events lectures
books podcasts institutes boot camps
jobs initiative signals videos etc and
when you click through those you can
find incredible events based on machine
learning in San Diego or in Boston or
whatever there's so many different ways
to categorically parse and find the data
that you're looking for and I love this
so it teach us about what you're doing
here with this computational Renaissance
platform and in a sense it's like a
really beautiful way to structure data
and make it easy accessible so there's
actually a really funny story behind
this I am I I put my apartment in San
Diego I call it the habitat and I
effectively invite people to just call
me up and go I'm in town and I want to
tell you something I want to tell you is
I want to share something
and I'm like okay I keep this antenna
open for interesting fascinating people
and and it worked you know one some-some
gentleman he he called me in he's like
hey I'm I'm in San Diego and I was told
I should meet you and you know you do
this a lot as well so and he just came
over and we started chatting we you know
we hung out and I shared with him my
OneNote document that organized all of
my dreams and stories and memories and
kind of all this stuff and he's like
dude this would look great on this
software suite Khoda actually encoded IO
and I'm like all right well you know
what what is that kind of so I wrote it
down I make sure that every opportunity
that flies by I have a way to capture it
right like that bunny yes you need to be
ready for the bunny the beauty he needs
to be prepared to capture right away and
examine it so you could see it
everywhere so I wrote it down right away
and you know that the moment that I did
it I was standing at my standing table
and there's just a profound experience
and I wish people can go through a
similar experience you know I think it's
a it's fundamental it's probably the
same feeling you get the first time you
use Google maybe even the first time
you're gonna ask a a AIA question and
it's gonna give you an answer that is
coming from something from a brain but
everybody hopefully is gonna experience
that one day soon but you know I was
standing there on my standing table and
it felt when I started using the
software I saw the future in front of me
that just this incredible visual you
know this reverie and the moment that I
saw everything I felt like the ground
had just collapsed under my feet it left
it disappeared and I felt like I was
flying no ground just flying and I
realized right there that a lot of
people who are I guess from a depressive
disposition you know or the kind of
those types of repertoire they would
experience like they're falling but I
felt like I'm flying and I simply
realized that flying is simply for
and forward in physics and that was kind
of the the experience and I wish people
experience that flying feeling of just
weightlessness and and momentum pushing
them towards a you know their passion or
their just what is calling them that
gravity
so yeah let's yeah to be able to capture
the per Fundy of ideas or of beauty and
then be able to organize it in a way
that can recall or they can share with
other people
is so critical and so yeah go ahead so
this system I'm sore as my Halloween
costume going forward is gonna be
database man mmm-hmm I really love
databases I think they're beautiful I'd
they had all this like starfish
databases they're different designs and
there's exotic formats and if you
organize data a certain way you really
get a incredible kind of clarity and
insight into this information and you
can you can see it from different
perspectives and you know so this system
that you saw over there that's I need it
for myself I built it from me in order
to have an ecosystem intelligence to see
every company in the in North America
China and Europe in South America a
little bit I needed to see that right so
that I could buy tagged understand what
are the opera what's the opportunity
matrix some of the other distributions
that I've designed have been for
personal kind of management of my
reveries or my memories my thoughts my
experience is my writing almost like a
four dimensional book for data and you
could jump in you could write something
tag it up and then you could fly around
in your thoughts as a powerful
experience and and I think a necessary
one to truly understand the tags that
hold the your information your ideas
there's certain buckets and and
templates and themes that you're
constantly cycling through and if you
could let them out externalize your
ideas and the things that swirl around
you actually get to see them for what
they are in exam
them and use them with context and and
and then the social network that we were
mentioning earlier the co network that's
actually also an externalization or a
digitization of my personal relationship
network so it's good I guess there's a
theme here right it's digitizing and
externalizing your experiences and
emotions and networks and relationships
in order to truly interpret them
understand them and leverage them to
create and and and inspire ya when when
I hear you talking about like being in
love with databases being in love with
the visualization of data and this
process of structuring and making it
relatable externalizing my consciousness
into some sort of a visual that I can go
and recall more easily the most profound
things of course we were talking about
this beforehand but there's so many ways
to do this this is with your big network
of contacts this is with all of your
ideas and your execution roadmap there's
all different ways to do this and so you
know how do we optimize that process of
taking that data structuring and
visualizing and creating a feedback loop
of your process of actual izing your
your vision into the world this is
extremely important to figure out I'm so
glad that you're super focused on this
and this is actually you were using this
word data metabolism which I really like
because we've been using also data
refining and I think they're so so
similar the process of now that data
silos are no longer they're breaking
down and in many ways decentralization
is moving forward there's so many good
ways to be able to find like right now
just take this example of your data
that's in your Google Calendar data
that's in your Google contact the data
that's in your Evernote or OneNote or
keep or whatever you're using for your
note-taking service there's no
harmonization between that data is for
you to further be able to gain profound
insights visualized even in your
networks like you have all these you
know Facebook Twitter Instagram LinkedIn
etc
the ownership of the data being on their
end and the limit of when do you ever
get a beautiful data visualization of
your own network and the people that you
can get in touch with that will help you
accelerate what you're doing all this
type of stuff these are things that
we're super passionate about seeing in
the future of the data Renaissance and
the computational Renaissance so data
metabolism you know I've been using that
word - I've been seeing a phenomenon mo
as an anthropologist self-trained I
would say obsessively I'm an obsessive
anthropologist so I didn't go to school
for it I just want to kind of make sure
everybody knows that but I have another
training it's called obsession for
culture and civilization anthropology I
started noticing that a lot of my
friends and a lot of the people around
me were flooded with data too much tea
too much information TMI and they were
unable to self actualize because there
was just so much data to process on a
daily basis like so many texts and this
and that and you got to do this and that
and people started to almost slow down
rather than speed up I just saw the
tremendous drop in productivity and I
was like wait a minute this phenomenon I
I I need to I need to jump over it and
experience it first so that I could
create templates for others to use
there's no interesting that becoming
more interconnected actually could
decrease productivity if we're not
careful about Hawaii so that data
metabolism I mean that's a maturity it
requires maturity but the most important
word of the 21st century by the way so
that maturity with data really like
using your cell phone as a tool and a
vehicle to achieve your you know dreams
rather than just being this attention
kind of gathering thing I believe in
cannot inattention economies but
concentration economies where you focus
and habits and focus or technology in my
opinion and that's something that some
of the networks that we're building are
designed to amplify and you know really
target kind of what do you want to do
and send you towards that
at with with momentum so yeah data
metabolism you know you really need to
be kind of careful to get rid of all of
the dings and pings and make sure all of
this information that you're gathering
is being used and relevant so it's
really a zit everybody needs to become a
data scientist yeah in order not to be
overwhelmed with data that's potentially
unnecessary interesting everyone becomes
a data scientist so that you can manage
the firehose of data that's being shot
into your face every single yeah some of
us have better data metabolism than
others like I can remember almost
everybody I've ever met and that can
recall people and faces and all that
stuff but my memory is very different
you're in horsing for signal for your
personal blueprint yeah absolutely so
you could engineer these data centers
for your personalized data centers
essentially to recall almost anything
and I often tell people why remember
anything when you could remember
everything and yet the way you do that
is you externalise your memory and you
leave so much space inside to actually
compute who rather than hold RAM and
there's just yeah I mean it's been
called the existential technology by
some people it really allows us a single
person to organize complexity it's so
funny when I'm in a conversation I go
hold on a second I need to get my
computer and then I go and I offload all
of the profound things I've been
capturing onto off of RAM into long-term
storage and I just go right back into
focusing on trying to make the profound
connections with the other person and
not focusing so much on the storage as
well on the data right you know yeah
we're in this period right now where
this form factor of the phone it's like
your attention has to be diverted and
you're you're always have to be kind of
going to your computer to truly capture
the context but some of my friends and
some of the things that I'm working on
are going to allow you to be present and
to truly just be while this thing is
ambiently
collecting your information good luck
with finding what
most profound to that person you have to
know that person's personal blueprint
you have to know what their want to
parse for and then you ambiently have to
capture it but this is all possible
source all Bob that's so my exercise was
a really big risk I took like three
months to experiment and do this and it
was that great risk because that was a
very valuable time period where I need
my data kind of prepared or else my
business and my relationships are gonna
you know suffer and but I took this writ
this leap of faith to basically go I'm
gonna try a totally alternative approach
just unconventional altogether in order
to see if there's a unfair advantage
that I can get through technology and
then once I've templated it and given it
to all of my friends I can then
reproduce it for the rest of the world
and one of the things that people should
appreciate right now is just with even
social networks the one that we're
building you can actually architect a
single master kind of template and then
you could infinitely replicate it yeah
and you could actually focus that
network's attention on people that love
bicycling or podcasting right and you
could tweak the parameters and the
actually the the culture and
anthropology you could reverse-engineer
anthropology so when most people go to
Burning Man or one of these events you
know III go to them but as an event
organizer I actually I'm experiencing
them in order to reverse engineer some
of the cultural perspectives that I see
there and some of the anthropology that
I see and I can apply that culture or
applied anthropology so this is the
people that are involved in humanities
and civilization and art and all that
stuff this is really where they turn on
and if they could just understand how to
use databases they can create incredible
resource systems for their communities
and for their families and their friends
and they could basically just scale
which is their consciousness there's all
of these yeah applications of
personalized ways to focus consciousness
on these given tasks and all you have to
have all these peddlers that you're
talking about earlier
now that help you know you've given this
one recently this this understanding of
anthropology and culture and the
dynamics there to help push along that
focus consciousness I love your push on
that it's so interesting too there's all
these different focuses on these on
these little like butterfly proto called
consciousness focuses genomics IOT
autonomous cars 5g technology super
intelligence blockchain all different
aspects of this it's just it's endless
just mentioned some of my favorite
buzzwords exactly and it's just and
these are the things that you can you're
creating these little pockets of that
are happening around the world in
different areas yeah you know I just
think right now this period this
computational Renaissance is a moment to
ask bigger questions and these periods
these epic periods actually they arise
when there's an existential risk to a
species so I'm a big kind of I'm a very
passionate about ancient Greek history
and Roman mythology and all this stuff
and I find that these epic periods are
really just for humans we transition in
those periods yeah and we ask bigger
questions because we finally have
reached a point where we now have the
ability to answer it and and you know
the 1970s were ye and before you used to
understand and manage capital the years
after that the next 10 20 years Google
came through and it was able to manage
information
I think Amazon has just arrived on the
scene to manage computation mmm you know
and and now we've just solved that
problem and I think the next few
questions are really gonna be about
consciousness understanding then that
this we're all leading to the same point
that same intersection we're just asking
it in very different languages and
accents and
but we're all leading to that very
fundamental question which I think you
asked in the beginning kind of are with
all one consciousness I think we're all
engineering a single consciousness and
we're transitioning almost the same way
that hunter-gatherers you know hunt it
went to kind of farm and living you know
in these small villages and then these
villages transformed into towns and then
towns went into cities and then super
cities and then megalopolis and now our
first summit in San Diego in that hour
for summit but our q1 summit is called
synthetic infrastructure and that's
about turning a city into an organism a
brain that manages all the
infrastructure and the water and you
know resilience for earthquakes and
fires this is really a thinking system a
city that thinks and communicates a
networked city and I mean you know
between you and me I believe that San
Diego's small enough to prototype these
solutions and then rapidly propagate
them to other cities around the world I
think there's a city to city c2c model
happening right now where you want to
buy a port sure we can sell you this USB
stick you want to buy an airport same
thing it's on another USB stick if it
fits right so you can now understand
infrastructure and template it again
getting back to that templating one-time
template and then iterating or improving
upon that template over and over and
over again until you have a finished
version this is 3d printing but of ideas
scaffolding ideas it's it's quite a
remarkable technology and I encourage
everyone to try so the synthetic
infrastructure summit that's coming up
in the q1 of 2020 yeah March 12th and
13th March 1213 to 2020 in San Diego
you're basically identifying all the
different data that's happening inside
of a city and you're structuring data
turning it into an actual brain an
actual more functional brain that's able
to produce what San Diego's goals are
what Denver's goals are what London's
goals are tel aviv's goals
consciousness ACEF from a city
perspective a city can be conscious if
you give it a brain if you give it a
brain the nervous system and in nervous
systems the IOT and the edge computing
the edge computing you know so we
recently came from a meeting with Intel
we were actually doing a video podcast
so I hope to have that up in a couple of
weeks who were producing a cool screw
screening but you know they really
talked about some fascinating kind of
approaches to engineering edge computing
and just to describe what that really
means it's actually the paradigm before
was this cloud model where you would ask
a question or a car would see a cam you
know the camera would see something I'll
go I see something it would go up the
wire and into the cloud and then the big
computer somewhere some supercomputer
some data center would answer that
question computationally and they would
send an answer back and just like the
brain I mean wow that's a lot of time
spent transform from here to here even
though it's a small distance when it
comes to neuroscience or when it comes
to biology and the nervous system these
split seconds are the difference between
life and death difference between an
accident or just a shift in in traffic a
caliper recalibration
so this new move towards edge computing
is really founded on this understanding
of the brain and and neuroscience and
and neuromorphic computing you know so
extra-low San Diego has some of the
leading research at the Salk Institute
on on brains and I guess that's really I
don't know one of the most exciting
areas if you're if you're into
neuroscience and cognitive sciences
that's your really positioning yourself
to not only understand but to explore
and pass through this world you know in
a way that you can actually experience
it just just just a new way you really
get to see the world in a profound way
and that's their second conference our
summit q2 fifty shades of gray matter
you got it okay
shades of grey matter yes computational
neuroscience behavioral psychology I
fundamentally believe that
we're transitioning again again
hunter-gatherer you know to to this farm
to the city to this biological structure
this megalopolis turned into an organism
with a nervous system as the highways
and the tunnels and the sewers being
reinforced with the new technology
well synthetic as 50 shades of grey
matter is really our mind and the wiring
behind that with some of these new
software's you're really able to go into
your subconscious and understand how
your neurons are firing you could feel
it you can go in you can control the
screen that touchscreen behind the
screen and you could add your own
weights again if you're if you're
building a machine that can interpret
the world through computer vision apply
it to yourself and now you have a
mathematical logic layer you can see the
world in math or in waves you can see it
in particles you could see it in n
colors you could you could really choose
which focus you want in which kind of
vision you want and you could apply that
and there you go it's human vision
computer vision so it's it's quite
astounding so 50 shades of gray matter I
you've all know Harare if you're
listening to this please please please
come and speak there I love that guy I
think is once or at some point us of our
time yeah yeah please read that sapiens
25:21 questions for the 24 yeah just
know that if you know that you're on the
right track so and some of these
speakers that are gonna be there and
some of the questions we're asking I
mean you know what is the future of our
species and how do our brains evolve
from here how do we make that decision
collectively because I don't want to
leave people behind I mean it's
necessary to adapt but but you will be
left behind if you're not able to to
read to to change tweak your brain and
to create kind of new ways of seeing
things and to be adaptive and to be
hyper you know just just to see
opportunity and beauty and everything is
is a superpower and and I think it's
necessary to understand yourself
self-reflect and
understand others and to you know learn
how to find beauty and others so and
that's why I continue to hang out with
you because it's tremendous beauty
inside of you and I see it you know so
much that it's it's it's radiating so
thank you thank you likewise and so then
what would you recommend them given all
of the computational Renaissance that
you just listed what would you recommend
as a skill for young people and adults
going into this computational
Renaissance era you know I feel really
so this trip right now I'm going to trip
with my team to to San Francisco and we
we hit up some of the major companies
out here to have these awesome
conversations about how we can
collaborate and you know all of that is
going very well
but I came here personally my trip plan
my goal for this trip was to conquer a
fear a single fear every trip every
journey must conquer one fear so a lot
of viewers or you might think that I'm
very comfortable in front of the camera
and today I am but this is at a very
different I used to have a lot of stage
fright look a lot and I mean a nervous
response that would constrict the throat
and would create this kind of I was too
afraid to raise my hand in class a long
time ago and it just to move from there
to there on all these fears to fear
everything at least once everything from
ghosts to the dark to relationships to
women everything was a fear at one point
and I've kind of become an expert at
overcoming fears so this particular trip
is about overcoming the fear of cold I
came here and I walked around the
redwood forest with shorts on it was
[ __ ] freezing but I came here to win
against the cold and to experience it
and to use my own weights I know what my
body feels about the cold wim HOF it
exactly I know what my body feels I feel
you but I said wait a minute let my let
me make my own heuristics so let me
tweak my own parameters so that was this
journey and I think every single journey
every relationship every
the expedition and I think you should
take expeditions today is about
conquering a certain fear so my goal for
every podcast and every media and
content that I produce is to push a
single person out there one person push
them towards their goal and help them
remove a blocker and just overcome a
single fear that's holding them back
from whatever it is that they decided to
do that's you know dude was it one
person if I can get we know we inspire
people can we awaken them can we help
them get towards their goals yeah no
just push a single person and that
person will push ten others over time
butterfly effect baby so yeah I love it
what are your thoughts on free will do
we have it is this all determined gonna
ask Sam Harris about that yeah you know
free will that's a good question and my
team has taught me to answer I don't
know over this last trip you know am I
free to do what I'm doing I think your
architecture your neural architecture
decides kind of what your
probabilistically going to do and then
it's your choice to choose out of the
billions of little subconscious kind of
things coming bubbling up your
experience in training and and the
history will decide on which three or
four probably the best options and then
you I guess decide which one of those
three you'll take you'll you'll you know
apply but I think you all we actually
experience a million different desires
at the same time and then our
consciousness or subconscious up
conscious and then the is somewhere in
the city of the mind you know a way that
all bubbles up I guess really the the
thing that I look at this and when I
look at
kind of that neuron there's a way to
most people's brains and and
subconscious they treat it as if it's a
surveillance system their consciousness
is a surveillance system of their
subconscious hey you where do I find the
answer give it to me now so I just tried
to answer that question and I went into
my subconscious with my consciousness
and I went you better give me an answer
and I scanned the entire neuron city for
answers and somes tried as hard as they
could like here here you go here though
but it's really about knowing where to
look inside that architecture that
always gives you the best answers which
part of your subconscious always gives
you the best experiences and emotions
and feelings and that's where you got to
look for answers so oh do we have a free
will I think we have the freedom to
select which part of our consciousness
or subconscious provides the answer okay
and then do you think that humanity is a
biological bootloader for digital super
intelligence meaning are we here in
order to bring on the next thing well
you know I think that I think that we
are just designed in a way architected
in a way through evolution to always
continue to ask deeper questions and to
always push kind of chip the rock a
little further to see what's behind it
so if I told you that behind this huge
stone there is you know a something
hidden there inside the rock
I guess people obsession of people with
obsession like me hmm have to keep
chipping at the rock in order to see
what's behind it and I'll spend my whole
life on it and
you don't even have to pay me to do that
I'll actually just do it on my own time
you know I'll just keep chipping away
and if AI is behind that then so be it
but I think I think you need to have
maturity to chip at the right rocks yeah
you said this was the most important
word of the 21st century this wasn't
interesting yeah
maturity you know I guess maturity
that's what that's what levels you up
like when you have a maturity towards a
certain concept or subject or like even
public speaking there's a maturity that
comes with practice and with doing it so
the maturity with building
super-intelligent is a maturity with
building super intelligence and this
thing could answer all of our questions
one day or it could bring about our
greatest nightmares one day and it's
really about I think giving the people
that have shown the most responsibility
in the past and that have the highest
levels of maturity and politics and
science and technology the people that
have demonstrated true leadership and
courage they're the ones that should be
given the freedom to chip away and to
stop when it's necessary and to choose
the rocks that we chip or to choose the
kind of you know that medium that that
whatever's behind there the way that we
birth out of the egg yolk that is to
plan it now the way that the tree grows
out of the planet yeah I think we need
to be more a lot more selective on the
people that are that we hold responsible
get rid of the deep state listen you
know conspiracy conspiracy if they feel
about that is their global ruling elite
Tristan most likely but but but but I so
actually I mean I've met a lot of these
people the answer is no they're not in
control because I understand the limits
of some of their perspectives and
intelligences so I've evaluated some of
these people I personally don't think
that they're they have that capability
technically even financially they kind
of can't control everything like that
and also in order to do that you truly
need to be a super anthropologist or AI
anthropologist to truly be able to
control because there's so much
complexity in the system so many dynamic
moving parts that the fact that one
person or a group of people could truly
model out all of the different
complexities that happen as a result of
tiny changes in the emergent you know
tiny changes create extraordinary
emergent properties that would you're
assuming that what they do outcomes the
way that they want it the way that they
expected and that's almost never happens
just to give you an idea of the assets
that people own these are such as the
paths we're family the Rothschild family
Rockefeller family asked our family
DuPont family etc all these different
bloodlines of the ancient lineages of
the planet let's give them these ass
let's give their assets just to give you
an idea of what is in control like of
the game of Monopoly railways banks
cotton sewing machines electric and
power gold and silver iron and steel
motor vehicle companies insurance
companies tobacco companies watch
companies land and real estate companies
food and household goods and that's only
a very small portion of what is actually
owned and that's not even getting into
the actual nuance of the names of all
the assets in those categories but just
to give you an idea of when you do kind
of own a vast majority of the resources
and of the
exactly what's going on on the planet
yeah that's just a food for thought you
know it's funny I mean I I saw I used to
work in the family office space and
helping family offices acquire all these
real estates and companies and all that
stuff that's part of my background and I
attend these events often times and I
meet these people and honestly they're
sweet incredible people that manage just
massive fortunes there's just people
they're human they don't really have
this extreme eeen they don't have this
conspiratorial kind of spirit to them
they want sex and love and and of course
there's a little bit of power involved
but no
and how much money you have is how did
you earn that money I think so did you
step on people's backs and shoulders and
throats along the way or did you bring
some sort of a very powerful value to
the world that actually inspired more
people's blueprints to be actualized and
that's a very thin and hard line to
parse and understand but to do it with
the most purity and the highest
intention of the maximization of
prosperity on the planet that's a very
important first principle to have all
the eyes you have so many of the route
issues do you think that one of the root
issues of all of the things that are
going on in the world is our lack of
interconnectedness the fact that we feel
serve is so separate from each other and
from nature and from reality from all
that is I think it's the lack of
maturity I think as a species we just
haven't matured collectively yet I mean
we're still having Wars and stuff over
really not important things honestly
it's just there's better ways to
collaborate most people have this
paradigm of competition that's kind of
one of my little um when I think of
Silicon Valley I think of competition
and but my I believe the new approach to
competition is actually competing to
collaborate if there's almost like this
super colony approach to that I study
ants and all these other species and
super colonies are a very effective form
of competition that's competing to
collaborate that's the dynamic that I'm
most inspired by and the one that I've
operate on yeah and it's almost like
instead of being a shark you're a
jellyfish swarm you know so there's this
different paradigm of fluidity and you
know I invite people to compete to
collaborate with each other because this
that we were talking about earlier yeah
you you just I don't think being a silo
or a shark today in the ocean just way
too much light you can be seen and you
you you know you you're you don't
synthesize well you don't
there's just too much inefficiency in
having a shark body in this new water I
have a lot of water metaphors
Millennials and Gen Z are sniffing out
corruption quite quickly so that's quick
questions last two on the way out are we
in a simulation
maybe I don't I don't find that question
to be particularly kind of it doesn't
bring me to the place of exploration I
think there's a ways to explore
simulation like I like chemical
simulations or physics simulations right
these high-performance computers that
could simulate chemical in firm attics
that could simulate quantum computing a
kind of you know phenomena that's really
a simulation in my opinion a
mathematical simulation you could
simulate the way that one
pharmaceutical interacts with different
meta you know bodies and genetic codes
so from a simulation belongs there is a
word when it comes to the simulation of
an actual reality I do like to think
about reality in the engine room of
reality and kind of going in and playing
with the knobs so is it a simulation I
guess I don't know enough about that
particular question to actually be able
to interpret it to actually be able to
feel what that's what simulation means I
guess I'm maybe ignorant of the of the
whole context behind it what would you
say is the most beautiful thing in this
reality curiosity why you know it's just
it's the starting point for everything
it's it's what is that why is that how
is that it's just it's just it's it's a
it's a basis for questions for asking
questions if you have a million
questions and you ask them in the right
order you can actually get a few answers
out of it and you get to see the world
and experience it for what it really is
and taste every flavor and you know me
to all the people I kind of have this
little theory that there's like twenty
thousand people are on the world that
make it spin right I mean realistically
and I want to meet all these twenty
thousand and explore how they do it and
learn and interact with them so you know
twenty-eight Pareto principle twenty
eighty eighty twenty so my goal is to
yeah just to experience people I fell in
love with people again I used to be I
used to hate to people seriously
seriously I mean it's it's you know I'm
very honest about that
the way I grew up and some of kind of my
upbringing there's that's a that's a
thing that I've reconciled a lot of
those contradictions and and traumas but
now I've learned to love people and to
see inside of them beauty and the
architecture and kind of their unique
geometries and I guess yeah love for
people is one of the most beautiful
things to appreciate it to be curious
about people I guess is to love them
really that that's how I would put it so
it's a curiosity directed as a laser
towards something but you need to
sometimes you're a flashlight and
sometimes your [ __ ] laser and you
point it at a question that's worth
solving yeah and if you were if you're
fortunate enough to have people around
you that illuminate this darkness with
flashlights you can act as a laser and
when they need a little light for their
laser you turn you open that laser into
your flashlight and you shine it towards
the place that they're trying to love it
you know so that's teamwork that's
collaboration that's yeah I think that's
the most important things that we need
to figure out as a species because man
do we need to explore more cave systems
and more of stars curiosity and
collaboration and making the right
ecosystems around that exploration will
process a that was very beautifully I
look when the
put throughout the episode and
leveraging the computational Renaissance
that we have now to structure the data
and to build the right brain cities to
make it happen all this type of stuff to
get back to some of those roots of
interconnectedness and embed that style
of feeling and emotion and awareness
into the future that we're building as
paramount as we move forward otherwise
the tree grows too crooked too much
suffering we can grow it with more
beautiful flowering along the way so
nice yeah I think I think that this is a
kind of one of those feelings that I
want to share like I have this a kind of
mo internal emotion - it's a share this
but I think right now during this
computational Renaissance so these
periods are extremely rare in history
like most people never have a chance to
to see light it's almost like sunlight
coming out of very very shaded clouds
you know and these these periods in
moments and places a most computational
cognitive revolutions happen in a very
isolated place you know with a very
short limited period of time I I know
for a fact there's one going on in San
Diego right now kind of this era where
it's an epic period with heroes and
villains to a certain extent and heroes
and monsters right but at the same time
this is a period that it's almost like
you're not allowed to be angry or upset
doesn't matter who you were before the
Revolution or the Renaissance it's about
who you're becoming that's the real
question here so whatever your baggage
your story your ego all these things
that you've held on to and they actually
don't matter at this line at this point
in the sand that's it they don't matter
going forward you could drop them drop
the anger the the fears you know just
drop the all of those things that you
believe all of this the retinue
mythology write your own new mythology I
think that's just an opportunity
these epic periods they are for writing
mythologies so if you respect the the
ancients you know this is a period to
write a new mythology for yourself for
your civilization for your city and yeah
just go out there meet other people and
create that's that's my message yeah
love it
Wow it's been such an epic conversation
Tristan thank you so much for thank you
some of them super honored to have you
on it's a big pleasure thank you so much
I love what you're doing man and yeah I
support it any way that I can thank you
come to San Diego I look forward to
introducing you to some people and would
love to share some ideas I love silicon
beach San Diego in LA there's so many
smart people down there I love it it's
been such a great conversation thanks
everyone for tuning and we greatly
appreciate love to hear your thoughts in
the comments blow on the episode let us
know if you're thinking about the
computational Renaissance about all of
these different ways to structure the
way we metabolize data and the way that
we execute leveraging network theory and
design and also all these other thoughts
about just do what's written on
innovation - labs Co computational
Renaissance check out those links in the
bio below also Tristan's LinkedIn
profile check that out as well and then
thank you or e for co-producing greatly
appreciate it thank you to the team
thank you to them and thanks to
Tristan's team that's here we love you
guys all oh yeah much we're the home you
said yeah amazing it's amazing to have
people that are from a different angle
than you I always thought that it was
supposed to be people just like me no no
no no no you actually have to have
people that are very different but
compatible there's just a little lesson
for teamwork yeah yeah yeah it's good
one and then also support the artists
the entrepreneurs the leaders the
organization's your communities that you
believe and support them and help them
grow you can find all of our links in
the bio below you can support simulation
you can find us on PayPal
cryptocurrencies Rhian all those links
are in the bio below and also design
click march and get paid check all those
links out and go and build the future
ever and manifest your dreams into the
world they love you very much thank you
for tuning in and we will see you soon
peace
awesome dude